[Music]
she looks good in your arm hey she'll be
happy at my house she will what's the
first thing you're gonna do when you get
inside to celebrate just quick my kids
take off these shoes
have a cocktail or two I just enjoy it
let it all sink in it's a really
exciting moment but it's overwhelming I
was gonna say is it over woman you feel
I feel like I look at you use your
coming trying to steal wrap your head
around the back you may see for sure man
it's exciting because you I just didn't
expect any of this and it's really
emotional for me I think about the
little girls out there who watches women
be the architect for their own stories
that write their own stories produce
them and act in them and take the power
back you know and be motivated by
motivating them the big moment for you
guys tonight Nicole and Laura your girl
how excited were to have four women
nominated for one show it's pretty
extraordinary and I feel really like the
TV Academy was so generous and the
audience's more embroiling the audiences
and just
people come up to me in Nashville and
New York City all over the place they
just love these characters and they love
that we're telling the truth about how
women really feel
[Music]